hallo leute hier ist wieder eure
fitnesswahn und willkommen zum
extremsten workout meines lebens
avengers als sandl
[Musik]
hey leute hier ist wieder eure
fitnesswahn und willkommen zu diesem
extrem sportlichen video
[Musik]
ich hoffe das wird natürlich alles
abverlangte ich war im evoque studio und
dort macht man mit work outs also haiti
und ich glaube das heißt high intensity
training das ist halt diese sportart wo
reifen umgeschmissen werden wo du ein
seil hoch klettert und wo du wirklich an
deine grenzen kommt der trainingsplan
intime und ich im fitnessstudio
absolvieren ist eigentlich schon
anstrengend genug aber kylie hat eine
andere art daran zu gehen können wir die
wie mein programm heißt
also ich hatte mir überlegt wie wärs
wenn wir erstmal was für die beine
machen bedeutet in dem fall stritten
schieben und sechs kurzen schritten
voran lage dass ich glaube es ein
anderer schlitten wir machen sechs
courts und flat wir gucken mal an wie
viel gewicht wie jungs schauen kann wir
machen auf jeden fall fünf runden das
heißt von kunden wie wiederholt das
ganze fünf mal dass wir gleich machen
also eine wiederholung verfahren ok
26 meter also eine bahn da hinten ist
nach jeder runde 45 sekunden pause und
dann starten wir mit der nächsten das
festmahl an ja ich mache erstmal
entspanntes war mal gucken uns die
bewegungen mal an ich erkläre dir worauf
du achten musst was wichtig ist wenn
natürlich die ganze zeit da und zum
schluss bringen wir dich nochmal zu
schützen aber darüber sprechen wäre wenn
es soweit ist
[Musik]
und wie bei an sportarten mussten uns
natürlich erstmal aufwärts
[Musik]
das war aus irgendeinem grunde mal
wieder anstrengender als es hätte sein
müssen
es ist es jetzt schon works war macht
vorbei nein wir sind immer noch da macht
das ist das warm up für die übungen
damit wie sie einmal durchgehen denn die
sie auch kennt weil ich kann ja nicht
einfach drauflos lassen und sagen mach
jetzt keine erklärte uns dann wie man
das rac 1 stellt also die halterung für
die stange die man auch seine schultern
legt ihr wollt dann die stange natürlich
ins bett legen damit wir im nachgang
gewicht drauflegen können das ist eine
übung die die ausbildung übung ist
grundsätzlich ein bisschen
anspruchsvoller nämlich die stange vom
boden zu schulter bringen damit sie dann
da anlegen könnte
mit geradem rücken aufheben und erst mal
einfach nur ganz steht ganz aufstände
gibst du den po nach hinten dienst nicht
über die stange und jetzt versucht sich
schnell hoch zu springen und die
ellbogen nach vorne zu müssen
es war nicht hübsch aber es war dann
mein motto bitte genau wo die stadt
liegt ich habe schon mal falsch gemacht
und ich glaube ganz viele andere das ist
wichtig dass du schon mal auf beiden
seiten den gleichen griff hast ganz ganz
auf passiert ist dass ich einmal hier
greifen da so ungefähr daumen weit
entfernt vom glatten teil kann man so
als groben richtwert sehen sind beide
hände greifen die stangen du steigst
rein wenn bevor du dich stange heraus
holst es ist wichtig dass die füße
direkt darunter steht sondern nächste
die stange in lacken bedeutet also auf
dem trapez mussten wir wollen sie nicht
hier oben am bibel haben sondern hier
auf den muskel liegen schulterblätter
zusammenziehen dann liebt sie gut auf
jetzt zwei schritte nach hinten und dann
ist da aber auch in meiner gleiche du
holst die flucht
wo nach hinten raus kommt einmal in den
slot sales die spannung kommt wieder
hoch wenn du oben bist ausatmen einatmen
wieder die spannung finden und im
nächsten sketch
wenn du fertig bist erst mal ganz nach
vorne laufen das wirklich stange hier am
reck koers und dann erst nach unten
absetzen ganzen fertig möchtest du das
mal wieder ausprobiert auf meine frage
wie man denn bei solchen übungen am
besten atmet hatte kylie eine super
metapher und zwar die coladose du kannst
es dir ungefähr vorstellen über so eine
coladose wenn die forscher ist und was
sie auf
der druck entweicht stresstest auf und
sie machen genau so kannst du das mit
dem körper vorstellen wenn er kein fan
druck nach außen durch die atmung es ist
es so dass das du einfach nicht genug
spannung hast du bist nicht gut genug
geschützt und wir benutzen die
bauchmuskeln ich richtig weil was
passiert wenn ich auf eine coladose
steige die zu ist wollen sie hält mich
einfach und genau das ist der planet
haben werden hier rausgehen
und jetzt probieren sitzen wie wir
richtig atmen können wir ein paar sports
ohne gewicht machen einfach mal um da
reinzukommen und da ist mir aufgefallen
wie tief man gehen kann
und combo so ist gut ankommen machen wir
noch
die zeit im anschluss dann schon die
nächste übung und zwar den schnitten das
ist der schritten wie bei gleiche
relativ weit unten greifen weil wenn er
von oben greift schiebt die ja auch das
eigene gewicht nicht nur nach vorne
sondern in den boden rein ist wollen wir
verhindern bedeutet wir greifen etwas
weiter unten ist mit zwei möglichkeiten
möglichkeit eins ist mit gestreckten
armen also hier richtig rein sieht brust
raus oder man lehnt sich hier ein das es
bleibt jedem überlassen wie er möchte
wichtig ist ihr stößt sich dann mit den
füßen weg rücken bleibt gerade erst aus
den beinen schön atmen zum umdrehen
wichtig dass ihr in bewegung bleibt
umdrehen und dann los
[Musik]
willkommen beim großen schlitten battle
die besten freunde anni gegen vanni
treten an und wer den schritten als
schnellstes auf der anderen seite krieg
es für immer der bessere mensch
reise
[Musik]
so anstrengend wie viel gewicht
anni und ich holen die ersten gewichte
keine gibt uns die letzten tipps und
dann wird ordentlich was weg geboren
also griffen alles dinge um die stange
herum und jetzt luftholen
cola dose sei die cola dose war
es muss ein kleines bisschen weiter
runter
[Musik]
du bist doch der ist da den hast du doch
weg gemacht ungefähr zentimeter noch
kommen
[Musik]
kennst du musst mir gerade einen
sicherheits was das schlimmste ist wenn
du dein beckord verpackt und ein coach
dann geht ihr macht ich sage wieder
zurück sind aber ihr kleid trägt so
ernst der sache hier ich glaube dass du
das kannst aber dass du keine spannung
ist du bist du
ich trete ich stelle mich hinter die
bühne gehen auch finden alle finger
drumrum schulterblätter zusammenziehen
luftholen stange rausnehmen zwei
schritte nach hinten wenn du dein stand
schon bereit stehen ok ich bereit
luftholen bauch fest wo nach hinten raus
und komm o komm o komm
[Musik]
besser war es dann als wir das komplette
gewicht runter genommen haben und ich
einfach mit der stange in diskurs gehen
konnte viel besser
wo nach hinten schieben komm komm
wir machen zusammen brad kam
die auf dem schlitten hat mir alles
abverlangt
auch zu schützen anni hat schon viel zu
lange pause wir hatten ja quasi dieses
zirkeltraining und nach dem knie beugen
folgte der schlitten und dann wieder die
kniebeugen und dann wieder der schlitten
bob kleine schritte
sehr schön besser sind beide der kunden
gewonnen und
entspannen durchschritten ich drehe
und lose sehr gute atmung bisschen
weiter runter aber der war schon schön
ein bisschen weiter runter sehr schön
[Musik]
animiert bern
[Applaus]
waren zwar jetzt nicht wie ich unter
parallel ist aber nicht so schlimm
gerade
[Musik]
2000 jahre später
teil 16
und glaubt mir es war wirklich nicht
einfach von der ein anstrengung zur
nächsten anstrengung zu wechseln
und eigentlich schon total kaputt zu
sein aber noch mal wieder zurückzugehen
und bis zu machen und immer wieder es
war ja immer kaputt ist ein
pulsmessgerät hätte
190 für den pulten meinem schritt
hier spielen
teil das war ja schon mal richtig toll
ich fühle mich jetzt richtig gut wie
geht es denn weiter wir machen jetzt
noch ein workout mit dem ressort bike
wir nennen es auch gerne etwas gerne
erst bike es ist eine maschine aus der
halle und die zeit vergeht langsam auf
die saison
das
lager eines holt bike ist ein fahrrad
mit ventilator ach ja und deine hände
sind auch pedal eigentlich ist alles
pedale du bist du bist eine große pedale
ihr seht unten rechts eine art pm zahl
ich möchte dass sie gleich immer über 50
liegt wenn ihr arbeitet tut mir das mal
ausprobiert man auf 50 zu kommen ist für
rund
321 wird auf 50 jahren begonnen
[Musik]
blatter
sehr schön beide fast 26
bei ist eine unserer übungen für den vip
ich zeig euch einmal ihr wollt möglichst
schnell und effizient zum boden kommen
bedeutet kann darauf setzen beide
springen nach hinten gekommen legt euch
auf dem boden komplett ab drückt euch am
besten in so einem schlangen moment hoch
weil sonst so spart ihr euch nämlich die
kraft werde ich zusammen springt auf den
ganzen fuß land nun schon möglichst
bleibt kommt hoch arbeit zusammen nehmen
kam hierbei unser papier nachdem wir
hier auf dem fahrrad mit herumgefahren
sind deine frau tun frau
landes weil leute meint hier noch nicht
genug geplante ab landes sehen wie folgt
auf diesmal worse landes bedeutet ihr
steigt nach hinten schräg nach hinten
hätte das nie würde uns dann auf den
boden kommt wieder nach vorne nach
hinten steigen
wir machen jetzt sechs stück versucht
das volk nicht schön nach außen zu
schieben das ist wichtig das ist nicht
nach innen kollabiert wurde das klischee
nach außen schieben sehr schön wenn ihr
mitgezählt habt könnt ihr dann sechs
auflagen wenn nicht macht ihr jetzt noch
vier letzte übung ist schon mal eben ab
märz bin gleich wieder bei euch
das dicke ende der app mit zu teuren
decken füße zusammen zu sein zusammen
mit hinter euch zum boden vor euch den
boden hinter euch zu boden würde ihn für
euch zu holen nehmt die hände mit als
würdet ihr den ball nach vorne werfen ok
also einmal vor dirk metz yamana
fußsohlen berühren sich so hinter dem
kopf auf dem boden würde uns vor den
füßen wohnen würde jetzt wo wir machen
jetzt fünf nimmt die aber vor natürlich
den ball nach vorne werfen schweren
medizinball nach hinten gehen einatmen
nach vorne kommen ausatmen sehr schön
[Musik]
gutes team wir sind wieder freunde
also immer und 15 leute jede minute
blieb die uhr 15 minuten langen es wird
drei runden in diesem fall minute 1
gemacht so viele profis geschafft minute
zwei ihr macht sie vielen landes
wirtschaft minute drei so viele tipps
minute vier so viele kalorien auf dem
bike dann eine minute pause und wir
starten wieder von vorne das ganze drei
runden lang lang gut ich stelle die über
15 sekunden schon zwischen time bedeutet
die arbeitet effektiv nur 45 sekunden
was gut für euch ist okay das ist wieso
das schlimmste menüs offener restaurant
karte finden kannst
ich starte die uhr frei
[Musik]
bei
bleibt
steht ja so etwas wie das krasseste
workout meines lebens und genau das war
es auch dieses zirkeltraining hat nicht
wirklich an meine grenzen es hat spaß
gemacht dieses fahrrad zu bewegen oder
auch dieses sit ups zu machen mit dem
kissen aber es war so anstrengend und
ich dachte in jeder runde jetzt das
war's
eine pause hat natürlich
durchatmet versucht durch die nase
einzuatmen überlässt es habe immer
wieder
120 sekunden
das ja so schön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist
russland
die kosten
die maschen
[Musik]
es war so anstrengend und mein kopf
wollte mir die ganze zeit sagen nein für
mich und während ich mich daran selbst
aus gehabt hat und diese stimme gesagt
hat du schaffst das nicht hat eine
andere stimme gesagt doch doch die
praxis
o
nein
falsch
und ich habe es geschafft ist war das
anstrengendste bord meines lebens aber
ich habe durchgezogen
[Musik]
ja also an ist jetzt auch auf temperatur
gekommen und jetzt geht's richtig los
bist gut durchgezogen und zur belohnung
gab es sogar von ihm einen recovery
sheikh sehr herzlichen dank dafür
sie müssen aus dem schamlosen feier
jetzt
und jetzt kommen wir zu allerwichtigsten
frage habe ich dort ein neues hobby
gefunden nein absolut nicht ich gehe
gerne zum sport auch weil es einfach
spaß macht und die übungen oder das
training hat spaß gemacht aber es stand
nicht im vordergrund im vordergrund
stand so eine anstrengung und so eine
zielstrebigkeit die ich bewundere
menschen wenn sie die haben also diese
richtigen bis zum maximum und dann noch
weiter aber das bin nicht ich gehe zu
der kategorie menschen die ins
fitnessstudio laufen ihre paar übungen
machen natürlich auch anstrengenden
übungen und auch ins schwitzen kommen
aber immer noch mit einem lächeln im
gesicht und ich finde das völlig in
ordnung also ich finde nicht dass es
schlechter ist als das andere ist muss
jeder für sich selber wissen was er beim
sport sucht es war einfach wieder mal
ein super projekt und ich hoffe ich
konnte euch mit diesem video in eine
neue welt einführen und vielleicht ein
neues hobby für euch entdecken schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare und schreibt
gerne was ihr so für sportliche
aktivitäten macht ich lass mich da auch
noch gerne inspirieren
ich habe letztens noch mal klettern und
da habe ich gemerkt ich mag glaube ich
doch klettern hätte ich nicht gedacht
aber klettern ist was für mich ja willst
du noch sagen abonniert mal wanne und
schreibt was ne bis in die kommentare
klinsmann wirklich
[Musik]